[Music]
I'd like to I'd like to welcome you to
the voice you're on Team ding-dong wait
take it away yeah I'm from Dallas oh
cool it's pretty much wrong you're from
Lincoln yes sir
that's poor Larry the Cable guy's from
is Nebraska let me connect with him on
something pastors
dr. power at the University of Illinois
champaign-urbana yeah love champagne I'm
from Sacramento California that's the
capital of California just so you know
where you phone if we put Worth Texas oh
wow
footwork that's my neck of the woods
she's on your team though love me some
Greensboro it's the home of Wrangler did
you know that
no no writers made yeah you're Tennessee
trivia is on points then state mammals
Iraq Penn you need to study those
geography oh no I did
[Applause]
call the paramedics
write down the scope hey I'm just
laughing because my mom won't stop
talking about your dimples I'm staring
right at a family tree mom oh come on
Alicia when you talk about how
good-looking that's cowboy right there
that's cowboy I just did a country song
with Blake show quit dropping my name
stop dropping the name I play a lot more
country than I used to
I am proudly a country artist that's all
I care about then that's all I want to
be country music is my life
you don't want most people as possible
to hear your message yeah sure I do but
they're gonna have to turn it to a
country station to hear it though
[Applause]
okay
well who do you not take your pill
[Applause]
hashtag King ding-dong
[Music]
you